ask about orgies yeah so how many people
are in orgy what's like a standard we're
having a Sunday picnic and it's an orgy
what's like a number of people at an
orgy oh I've been I've only recently
started hosting orgies but I have been
to a lot of orgies I would say like the
median is maybe 15 people I like how you
say median versus mean okay median is 15
people what's the dis what's the gender
distribution usually uh usually about
even it's like ideal if you can get more
women than men in most of them I've
recently been hosting free use orgies or
do you just were consent is assumed by
default when you enter and of course you
can revoke it anytime or go over a whole
bunch of rules to make sure it's very
safe you like have wristbands so
nobody's actually doing anything they
don't want to but uh and in those ones
you have to have more men than women I
thought free use was like
consensual like at any time
but it's at any time within the
constraints of this building or
something like that you know yeah so at
the orgies it's like you buy entering if
you wear a wristband uh then you are
like by default opting into consent so
people don't have to like do a thing
where they negotiate with you and like
to be like is this okay it's just the
default is like you just go for it and
if they want you to stop they say the
safer like red don't and then you have
to stop
um and we do like exercise in the
beginning of people saying red to make
sure that everybody knows exactly what
the rules are what's your favorite safe
word red right when I first started
doing like weird kinky [__] I was like
oh let's make a safe word and we pick
the word foliage I was like that's goofy
right and then but then it eventually
came a time where I did actually in fact
want to say the safe word and I couldn't
I was like like in agony I was like
crying like I can't make myself say this
stupid word right now
foliage so after that it's like red
doesn't matter I don't care it's not
funny we're just going with very simple
very practical how does an orgy compare
sexually uh to like a one-on-one sexual
experience
um like what is the same ballpark or is
it fundamentally different
I mean the experience of all both orgies
and one-on-one sex could be like really
high variety there's a high variety but
you kind of it's a little bit like
you're having sex with someone but
you're surrounded by really realistic VR
porn of other people having sex okay
cool and sometimes it's like three sums
also like maybe there's another person
involved but it's hard to like have a
whole bunch of people on one in one
cluster because usually there's kind of
different little clusters of people
having their experience sure I was part
of a 10 woman orgy it was a total
lesbian thing and that felt like a
writhing cluster it was very nice
but typically you kind of separate out
with like very small PODS of people
doing stuff